[Applaudissements]
bonjour à toutes et à tous tout d'abord
merci à l'équipe tlx pour l'invitation
aujourd'hui
pourquoi suis-je devenu océanographe en
fait je voulais venir glaciologue mais
au moment du choix de stages de master
cette année là il n'y avait pas de sujet
en glaciologie alors j'ai choisi un
sujet en océanographie en pensant qu'un
jour ils m'amènerait peut-être à la
glaciologie mais en fait grâce aux
expéditions océanographiques que j'ai le
privilège auquel j'ai pu participer à
travers les océans du monde l'océan est
devenu ma passion et quand on est en mer
ce que gilles me plaît le plus c'est de
voir vivre écoutez respirer oui l'océan
vit et respire ils nous offrent des
dégradés sublime de bleu turquoise la
vue de ces des seaux d'eau douce aux
couleurs bleues blanches aux dimensions
immenses qui nous rendent si petit
à leur couleur dorée
à ses habitants du grand sud sur le pack
de glace ou bien dans les airs qui nous
émerveille à ces poissons exotiques aux
coloris et aux formes si différente qui
illustrent la richesse de la
biodiversité marine et l'océan c'est
aussi 97 % de l'eau sur terre
80% des organismes vivants ils occupent
71 % de la superficie du globe il est
responsable d'à peu près 50% de
l'oxygène produit sur la planète un des
poumons de la terre
les poissons permettent à plus de quatre
milliards d'individus de pouvoir
satisfaire au moins 15% de leurs besoins
en protéines animales
le commerce mondial se fait à 90% par
voie maritime et enfin on estime à que
l'océan abrite à peu près 80% des
ressources minérales de la planète
l'océan respire mais il respire de plus
en plus mal alors chez océanographes
mais parfois je suis un peu aussi nomo
log les ausculte l'océan plus je le voix
étouffée
et il ya vraiment urgence à rendre son
souffle à l'océan nous sommes dans la
grande accélération de l'air repos scène
les activités humaines ont déréglé
l'horloge géologique
on voit ici à droite les tendances du
système terre
et à gauche les tendances du système
socio-économique sur les 300 dernières
années toutes les courses sont à la
hausse pour les tendances du système
terre accroissement des gaz à effet de
serre co2 méthane protoxyde d azote
surpêche perte des forêts tropicales
pour n'en citer que quelques-unes à
gauche ces tendances du système
socio-économique accroissement de la
population mondiale surtout en milieu
urbain
accroissement de l'utilisation de
fertilisants de l'eau transports
le dernier rapport du des experts du
climat giec ipcc en anglais nous
confirma sans équivoque le réchauffement
du climat
je vous présente ici
les diverses trajectoires possibles du
système terre jusqu'en 2100 on regarde
ici l'augmentation en température de la
surface du globe la courbe en bas en
bleu qui correspond à l'accord de la
coop 21 de paris est donc le schéma
optimiste
1.52 degrés d'augmentation en 2100 les
courbes rouges brunes
c'est ce qu'on appelle le scénario
business as usual on continue d'émettre
des gaz à effet de serre au même rythme
que maintenant
il le dernier le récent rapport des
experts du ciel nous indique qu'en fait
la terre est plutôt sur la trajectoire
jaune entre les deux intermédiaires
2.73 degrés d'augmentation en l'an 2100
alors comment se répartit cet excès de
chaleur
eh bien on voir pour un scénario à 1.5
d'accroissement globale ou à 2 degrés ou
4 degrés
la chaleur serait partie entre
continents et océans mais les océans
absorbent une grande partie cette
chaleur et en particulier les régions
polaires
donc réchauffement climatique
réchauffement océanique mais également
perte d'oxygène dans les océans beaucoup
moins visible ici les points en rouge
sont les épouses les sites océanique
côtier
où les valeurs d'oxygène sont très
faibles leur nombre a été multiplié par
dix sur les 50 dernières années en bleu
ce sont les eaux anoxique c'est à dire
dépourvu d'oxygène leur volume a été
cadre clés sur les 50 dernières années
sur ces 50 dernières années l'océan a
perdu 77 milliards de tonnes d'oxygène
cela va-t-il continuer
oui les modèles du giec prédisent que
jusqu'en l'an 2100 quelle que soit la
trajectoire que va suivre le système
terre nous aurons une perte
additionnelle de 2 à 4 % du contenu
global en oxygène des océans
alors comment tu ont pris connaissance
de ce processus ici je vous montre pour
le mois de juin 2021
l'ensemble des systèmes d'observation
que l'on a sur l'océan mondial alors on
y voi des lignes le bateau marchand
régulière puis une multitude de petits
pois qui ne sont pas les shales sinon on
ne verrait pas
par exemple les points verts ce sont des
baux et des mouillages en un point fixe
équipés de capteurs métérologiques
océanographique au milieu du pacifique
tropical
tous les autres points sont des
plateformes véhicules autonomes qui
dérivent au gré des courants
équipe et l'instrumentation si on
regarde
uniquement ces capteurs c'est plate
forme autonome celles en bleu clair
correspondent aux boîtes surface celle
qui dérive en surface au gré des
courants celles en bleu marine les
points bleus marines correspondent à ce
qu'on appelle des profileurs argo qui
sont capables de descendre dans la
colonne d'eau et de remonter en
acquérant des mesures de température de
salinité de pression
les petits pois roses correspondent à
ces mêmes véhicules argot équipés de
capteurs qui mesurent par exemple la
concentration en oxygène dissous alors
si on regarde par exemple au large du
chili le déploiement d'un de ces profils
heures ça vous donne une dimension de la
taille par rapport à l'humain
il est mis à l'eau à partir d'un navire
ici c'est des navires de la fondation
tara
il va descendre sa profondeur du parking
à 1000 mètres il a dérivé pendant dix
jours à cette profondeur et ensuite ils
remontent et quand il fait son ascension
il acquiert en continu les mesures de
température ici en rouge salinité en
bleu et oxygène dissous en jaune quand
ils arrivent en surface il transmet ces
données en temps réel à un ensemble de
données ici le centre ifremer à brest
ensuite il redescend
il redirige pendant dix jours et il
remonte et ainsi de suite
alors si on regarde de créer le profil
en oxygène dissous en surface on a à peu
près 200 micro molle on est à saturation
équilibre avec l'atmosphère mais vous
voyez qu'il ya une zone entre 200 et 400
m où la concentration devient très
proche de zéro nous sommes en
concentration d'un homo l'air il est
très difficile pour les organismes de
respirer
tout écart par rapport à ce niveau
représente un défi à ces espèces ayant
évolué et s'étant adaptée à ces niveaux
de concentration pour leur vie
quotidienne
alors
pourquoi parce qu'il est beaucoup plus
difficile de respirer dans l'eau que
dans l'air pour un volume de données il
y a beaucoup moins d'oxygène que dans le
volume d'air correspondant un litre
d'air ses 1,3 g on a zéro point 3 g
d'oxygène un litre d'eau s'apaisent la
famille g et on a zéro point 0,08 g
d'oxygène à saturation c'est à dire en
surface mais quand on descend dans la
colonne d'eau comme dans cette couche de
104 semaines par exemple au large du
chili on arrive vers des concentrations
et knoxy qu on n'y a presque plus
d'oxygène
donc si la concentration en oxygène
continue à décroître les organismes
l'incapacité des organismes à pouvoir
respirer correctement aura une influence
sur leur métabolisme leur croissance
leur fécondité leur production leur
poids leur taux de mortalité naturelle
alors quelles sont les causes de cette
désoxygénation
le réchauffement climatique plus hinault
et chaude mois elle a d'oxygène
plus innover chaude on a une réduction
du brassage entre l'eau sur l'océan de
surface oxygénée et les eaux sous
jacente naturellement moins oxygéné par
ailleurs la faune marine a besoin de
plus d'oxygène lorsque m lorsque l'eau
est plus chaude alors dans les zones
côtières on a un processus aggravants de
plus le trophies à sion les pratiques
agricoles les engrais qui sont lessivés
sur les eaux littorales
apports des nutriments qui permettent
des efflorescences algal de développer
lorsqu'elles se décomposent
elle consomme de l'oxygène c'est un peu
la problématique de certaines zones des
côtes bretonnes
fort de ce constat la commission
intergouvernementale océanographique de
l'unesco a mis sur pied la décennie des
nations unies pour les sciences
océaniques au service du développement
durable 2021 2030 il s'agit de restaurer
un océan sain et résilients où les
écosystèmes marins sont protégés
restaurer et bien gérer un océan durable
et productifs qui assure
l'approvisionnement alimentaire et
l'économie sociale est ce que l'on
appelle la blue économie un océan
propres ou les sources de pollution
comme les plastiques sont identifiés
réduite voire éliminer un océan prévu où
nous sommes capables de prévoir l'état
océanique et sa variabilité sur le long
terme un océan sur où la vie et les
moyens de subsistance sont protéger des
aléas des dangers d'océan comme les
tsunamis par exemple
un océan transparent et accessible
avec un accès ouvert et équitable à tout
un chacun aux données à l'innovation à
la technologie à l'information
un océan inspirant et engageant où la
société s'engage pour préserver ce
patrimoine universel et assurer le
développement durable des mers et des
océans
qu'elles sont des outils que peut-on
faire la boîte à outils est simple
il nous faut des mesures beaucoup plus
de mesures actuellement
et surtout sur le long terme si l'on
veut pouvoir appréhender les tendances
il nous faut des observations pérenne
sur le long terme
il nous faut des satellites qui nous
informent sur les courants marins la
température de surface de la mer les
vents et l'ensemble des données que l'on
est in situ collectés dans l'océan de
façon autonome grâce à des navires
océanographiques et les données
satellites nous permettent de valider
ces modèles de prévision océanique et
donc de lait fiabiliser
mais voilà pour avoir une approche
totalement intégré
il manque une composante
vous nous la société
est en effet il est extrêmement
important d'avoir ce dialogue ici lors
d'une école d'été en chine où les
étudiants qui venaient du monde entier
ont établi un dialogue avec des
responsables de fermes d'aquaculture en
mer de chine dialogue extrêmement
intéressant à droite les mêmes étudiants
sur un navire océanographique en train
d'apprendre à utiliser les instruments
et comment les déployer en mer donc ce
dialogue avec la société est un maillon
essentiel
nous avons lancé dans le cadre de cette
décennie le programme good for global
ocean à oxygène liquide
2021 2030 pour rendre son souffle à
l'océan
cela va nous permettre
de fournir des données d'observation de
la connaissance
qui permettra au monde industriel à la
communauté scientifique à la société
civile
de co développer ensemble les mesures
pour atténuer les impacts de la perte
d'oxygène sur les écosystèmes à
ces approches de coûts développement
sont absolument essentiels pour
préserver les services écosystémiques
rendus par les océans à l'humanité
alors il existe des solutions
la première incontournable réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre pour
réduire le réchauffement ce qui veut
dire accélérer la transition écologique
que chacun d'entre nous travaillent à
son empreinte carbone individuel
la seconde créer des aires marines
protégées pour que les espèces les plus
vulnérables à la sfic ci puissent
trouver refuge dans ces zones
et enfin pour le milieu côtier
changer de pratiques agricoles beaucoup
moins d'engrais
ce lessivage arrive dans les eaux
côtières provoquant la knoxy
et enfin last but not least
éduquer
l'éducation
les solutions sont là elles existent il
suffit de les mettre en oeuvre et nous
comptons sur vous je vous remercie pour
votre attention
[Applaudissements]